ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูนิคสวัสดีครับครูหญิง
สวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนนะครับ
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ก็เขียนวันที่ก่อนเนาะเดี๋ยวโอเคผู้หญิง
เขียนก็ได้ค่ะครับ
ตวา
แป๊บนึงนะคะข่าวขอครูให้ใหญ่หน่อย
ประชานิดนึงนะคะนักเรียน
ไม่ค่อยถนัดค่ะนี้นะคะลืมเอา iPad ขึ้นมา
โอเคได้นะคะโอเคโอเคคุณนี้คะวันนี้วัน
อะไรคะวันนี้วันวันพุธครับสามวันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันที่แถวนะพี่ตูน x หรือวันที่ 8
ครับ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มิถุนายนเมื่อกี้คุณเด็กจะพูดพฤษภาแล้วนะ
เขียนเดือนแล้ว
โอเคยีสต์ยังไงเดียวนะตีผชอะไรคะที่ผช
2565  up  a คศอะไรคะปีคศ 2
022 ครับขาแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะ
ที่บ้านคอร์ดที่นี่นะครับที่ที่คุณนิด
อยู่ณตอนนี้ 8 โมง 11 นาทีตอนเช้าครับ
ชาย 8 โมงเช้าเนาะใช่เราที่ประเทศไทยครับ
ที่ครูหญิงอยู่ตอนนี้กี่โมงครับตอนนี้ที่
ประเทศไทย 2
อ.ทุ่ง 1 นาทีค่ะนี้ก็เป็นตอนกลางคืน
ที่ไทยเป็นตอนกลางคืนก็เวลาของครูหญิงกับ
เวลาของครูนิคตรงข้ามกัน
ชายก็ของคุณนิคกลางวันของถ้าคุยกลางคืน
ชายหาดจะวะแต่ที่นี่นี่จังกลางวันตอนนี้
ก็อากาศไม่น่าไม่อยากตื่นก็กรรมตกอ๋อโห
วันนี้วันนี้ที่กรุงเทพฯประมาณ
คิดว่าประมาณ 4 โมงนะคะ 4 โมงเนี่ยฝนตก
แล้วก็ลมแบบลมแรงมากขอ
ตอนนี้ที่นี่ก็น่าจะเหมือนเหมือนกันที่
กรุงเทพฯเพราะคนตกลมแรงแบบ
ถ้าแพงมากแล้วก็เพราะอากาศแบบเนี้ยคุณนี้
เห็นแล้วขึ้นในเถอะขี้เกียจ
ขับนอนเนาะก็อยากนอนมากกว่าเอาแล้วก็ก็
อาทิตย์ที่แล้วเนี่ยคุณนี้ก็เบรคไป 1
อาทิตย์ด้วยใช่ไหมคะแล้วตื่นมามาเจออากาศ
แบบมืดฝนตกก็ขี้เกียจว่าขึ้นใช่ไหมใช่ขี้
เกียจมากขึ้นหรอว่าไม่อยากไม่อยากทำอะไร
เลย
จ้าใช่ๆครับก็
ครูหญิงอาทิตย์ที่เราคุยหญิงทำอะไรไหม
ช่วงไว้ครับก็เหมือนเดิมก็ผู้หญิงก็สอน
แล้วก็ทำงานเหมือนปกติแต่ว่า
คุยนะไม่ได้เจอคุณอีกไง
อาทิตย์ที่แล้วเนี่ยไม่ได้เจอครูนิคนะจะ
ไปไหนมาคะคืนนี้เนี่ยไปเที่ยวมาฮ่าๆๆไป
พักผ่อนเพราะๆทำงานแล้วอยากเที่ยวอยาก
หยุดครับฉันก็คุณนิดไปไหนคุณครับ
ไปเที่ยวมากี่วัน
นี้คุณนี้ก็ลืมแล้วไปเที่ยวมา 4 วันออน
แล้วไปเที่ยวในอเมริกาหรอคะหรือว่าทาง
ครับใช่ไปเที่ยวไหนอเมริกาก็คุณนี้กลับไป
ที่รัฐโคโลราโด
ข่าวไม่รู้ว่าครูหญิงเคยได้ยินไหม
เคยได้ยินค่ะเคยได้ยิน Colorado แต่แต่
ไม่รู้ว่าอยู่ตรงไหนนี่อยู่ตรง
อันนี้เป็นตาอเมริกา
ดีนะมีก็ไม่รู้ว่าดาเมริกาถูกไหม
รัฐโคโลราโดเนี่ยอยู่ตรงไหนของอเมริกา
เหรอลืมอาลาสก้า
อลาสก้าอายุตรงนั้นฮ่าๆๆโอเคก็เดี๋ยวครูน
นิจะคนนี้เจอเขียนได้ยังไง
นะครับค่ะได้ค่ะคุณหรือหัวปากกาหรือเจอ
คุณอาจจะต้องกดตรง View  Option ข้างบน
แล้วว่าจะมี and อะไรนะน้อโอเคนะครับจะละ
โอเคก็ของอันนี้ณตรงนี้เนี่ยคือ
คู่นี้อยู่ตรงนี้
อันนี้เห็นไหมครับแล้วทำไมมันขึ้นเห็น
อ่ะใช่เพราะว่าของคุณนิดมันมีวงกลมมันไม่
อยู่บนแผนที่
ก็เห็นวงกลมไม่ได้อยู่บนแผนที่เหมือนกัน
เออแล้วทำไมมันไม่อยู่ตรงไหนแต่คุณภูดิษ
เขียนบนแผนที่ใช่ไหมคะไงใช่กูนี่ไก่เขียน
บนแผนที่เอาแบบนี้ครับเดี๋ยวเดี๋ยวแป๊บ
นึงนะเดี๋ยวคุณไม่รู้วันนี้แชร์ไหมเดี๋ยว
คนนี้เอารูปภาพให้ดูก็ได้ได้ค่ะเดี๋ยวให้
ครูนิคหาให้ดูว่า
Colorado อยู่ตรงไหนครับถ่ายถ้าถ้านัก
เรียนเป็นคนอเมริกาก็รู้น้องก็น่าจะรู้
ว่า Colorado อยู่ตรงไหนแต่ถ้าไม่ใช่คน
อเมริกาก็เหมือนครูหญิงก็อาจจะเอ๋อยู่
ส่วนไหนในอเมริกาๆเราอเมริกาเนี่ยประเทศ
ใหญ่มากค่ะใหญ่มากๆที่ว่าอเมริกามี 50
รัฐเธอจะมีมีหลายๆรัฐที่ใหญ่กว่าประเทศ
ไทย
คือใช่ไหมน่าจะนะก็ไม่รู้เคยเคยได้ยินเคย
ได้ยินนักเรียนบอกว่ารัฐเท็กซัสใหญ่กว่า
ประเทศไทยเออใช่เพราะเท็กซัสเนี่ยเช็คซัส
น่าจะใหญ่ที่สุดเราก็อลาสกาอาลาสก้ากับ
เท็กซัสเนี่ยนน่าจะขนาดพอๆกันนะค่ะอ่ะมี
อะไร
โอเคได้ค่ะมาแล้ววันนี้เราใช่ไหมเห็นค่ะ
เห็นค่ะ
อ่าเห็นอันนี้ก็คือแผนที่ประเทศอเมริกา
ใช่ๆอันนี้นะครับก็ก็
เมืองนี้ครับมึงนี้จะเป็นเบื้องที่
คุณนี้มีอยู่อันนี้นะรัฐนี้
สวิสสิ้นสูงคอนเซนกูนิดอยู่ทางเหนือเลย
เนาะอยู่ทางเหนือข้างบนเลยก็ก็หน้าหนาวนะ
ก็หนาวมากใส่แล้วค่ะเข้าใจผิดที่คุณนิด
บอกว่าหนาวเพราะว่าอยู่ติดทะนาดาๆอยู่ติด
กันเลยเราโอ๊ขนาดตอนนี้นะจริงๆแล้วเนี่ย
หน้าร้อนแต่พอมีฝนตกอ่ะมันก็ประมาณ 15
องศานะ
ใช่ใช่ก็จะมันก็หนาวอ่ะไม่
เข้าใจ
อันนี้ครับนักเรียนน่าจะเห็นอันนี้คือ
Colorado ค่ะ
ก็กูนี้กาดนั่งเครื่องบินนั่งเครื่องบิน
ไปแต่ที่นี่ครับก็นั่งเครื่องบินประมาณ 2
ชั่วโมง
เลขเชียงใหม่เนาะกรุงเทพเชียงใหม่ชั่วโมง
เดียว
กลางสไตล์งั้น
ถ้าภูเก็ตภูเก็ตเชียงใหม่เนี่ยระยะมัน
เหมือนกันอ้าโอเคก็ชกไรอยู่นะไกลไกลไหมก็
เคครับคุณนิคเนี่ยชอบนั่งเครื่องบินไป
เที่ยว 2 ชั่วโมงคูนี้เนี่ยไม่เป็นไร
ใช่ครับก็กลับพรุ่งนี้ไปเที่ยวที่
Colorado โคโลราโดไม่หนาวใช่ไหมคะไม่
หนาวเหมือนวิสคอนซิน
หนาวนะ
ใช่แต่ว่าที่หนาวและมีลมมีลมแรงเพราะว่า
คอนโดราโด้เนี่ยเป็นรัฐที่อยู่คนไทยจะพูด
ว่ายังไงดีมันจะสูงกว่ามันจะสูงกว่าร้าน
อื่นๆเพราะว่า Colorado เนี่ยมันอยู่บน
เขาค่ะอ่าเข้าใจนะครับ
เสาร์ใช่ไหมๆมันมีภูเขาเยอะเหมือนอย่างยก
ตัวอย่างนะครับก็
ปกติเนี่ยคือพอไปถึง Colorado เนี่ยเขาจะ
บอกเลยว่าเหมือนกันระดับความสูงเนี่ยเขา
เรียกว่าเอาที่ถูกใช่ไหมคนไทยใช่ระดับ
ความสูงของพื้นเนี่ยจะสูงกว่าร้านอื่นๆ
ประมาณ
5,000  5,000 พูดนะ
ใช่ผู้หญิงก็ไม่รู้ว่า 5,000 บาทอื่น
เขียนไม่ได้
ก็นะเดี๋ยวครูเล็กชารอบ akaz ปิดหน้าจอ
ให้ต้องโอเคโอเคอ่า
ฮะ
โอเคกลับสู่
ใช่มันสูงกว่า 5,000 ก็เดี๋ยวนึกลอง
เปลี่ยนเป็นไว้เดือนนี้กระดาษ
เราครูนิคไป Colorado โคโลราโดก็เป็นรัฐ
ที่ได้เหมือนกันนะอยู่จากในแผนที่เขาใหญ่
นะ
อันนี้นะเดี๋ยวออกอันนี้ครูหญิงเห็นหน้า
จอเนาะค่ะอยากก็อยากเห็นประมาณนี้แค่นี้
อะไรก็อันนี้ครับสมุดอันนี้นะเป็นคนนี้จะ
เขียนตรงนี้นะเป็นวิสคอนซินใช่ไหมคะจอที่
Colorado เนี่ยระดับพื้นปกติเนี่ยมันก็
จะสูงกว่า
อากาศก็จะหนาวกว่าตายเข้าใจเนาะอยู่ที่
สูงมันก็มีลมมากกว่า
ใช่ๆก็คุณนี้ก็ต่อไปเราก็คุณนิดที่ไปที่
นี่เนี่ยเพราะคุณอีกชอบภูเขาค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้ไปเดินเขาหรอคะที่โคราชไอ้ๆกูจะ
ไปเดินเขาครับก็เลยสนุกมั้ยสนุกๆก็ก็คุณ
นิดเนี่ยไปเดินเขาสองที่
สองสามที่ 3 ที่ใช้ครับ
ฮ่าๆ
4 วันนี้นะคะ 4 วันเดินแถว 3 ที่ๆไปเดิน
ไม่เยอะเดือนไม่เยอะครับเพราะว่าก็ที่รัก
ประมาณ
ค่า
กิโลเมตรอ้า
ๆครับ
เดินประมาณกี่ชั่วโมงอ่ะคะคุณนิค 5
กิโลเมตรพรุ่งนี้เนี่ย 5
5-6 กิโลเมตรเนี่ยคุณนิดเด้อเดือนประมาณ
2-3 ชั่วโมงครับ 2 ถึง 8 ชั่วโมงโอเคอะ
เข้าใจเข้าใจแล้วทำไมครูนิดเดินได้หลายๆ
ที่เหอะนกแต่เดินเสร็จก็ปวดขาเหมือนกันนะ
เราไม่ได้เดินบ่อยๆๆๆ
ก็แต่ว่าอันนี้ครับเพราะว่ารัฐเนี่ยมัน
อยู่มันอยู่บนเขาใช่มากคู่นี้ก็เดินเรา
เหนื่อยง่ายกว่าปกติเพราะความสุขน่ะระดับ
ความสูงวันนี้อากาศเหมือนมีออกซิเจนต่ำคะ
ออกซิเจนมันก็ให้เขาออกซิเจนมันน้อยแล้ว
พอเดินเนี่ยสมมติมันเดินขึ้นใช่มากมาสูง
พืชน้ำอัญชันแบบอย่างนี้มันไม่ได้ปกติมัน
ต้องขึ้นเขาเป็นเพราะมันชันอากาศมันก็
เปลี่ยนเร็ว
แต่ก็ทำดูเขา
ใช่
โห
ใจไม่ได้อย่างนี้มันก็จะฉันครับค่ะต้องมา
เดินไปแป๊บเดียวอ่าประมาณ
2-3 นาทีนะคุณเล็กเดินแล้วคุณกลับ
ขอบ
แล้วคุณนี้ก็งงคนนี้กลับไม่รู้ว่าเอ๊ะมัน
เพราะอากาศมันน้อยหรือคุณนิกะห์อายุมาก
เห้ยคุณนิคคู่นี้ไม่ได้เดิน 2-3 ชั่วโมง
นะอันนี้มันแค่ 2  3 นาที
รถไฟเกิดครูติ๊กเลยแบบเอ๊ะมันเพราะอะไร
เบอร์อะไรค่ะเพราะว่าอากาศมันนอนทั้งสิ้น
เช่นมันน้อย
ให้มันก็เลยเหนื่อยง่ายเราก็ที่ที่น่าสน
อยู่ในน้ำผู้หญิงเพราะว่าอยู่บนภูเขาใช่
มากคุณนี้จะเดินเดินเดินเดินไปก็
มันก็ไม่มีหิมะนะแต่พอเดินขึ้นไปสูง
เรื่อยๆเนี่ยะหิมะตกค่ะ
ใช่อากาศมันเปลี่ยนตลอดครับเวลาเดินขึ้น
ภูเขาแล้วใช่สิมะนะหิมะตกลงมาอู้ฮู้ว่า
เอาเบื่อมากเบื่อมะใช่เนี่ยอย่างตรงนี้
ครับแค่นี้นะจะมีหิมะชนิดเดินขึ้น
แล้วเราต้องนี้หิมะตกละแต่
ข้างล่างตรงนี้นะ
ไม่มีหิมะเลยรู้อากาศมันก็เปลี่ยนแบบเร็ว
มากเหมือนกันนะคะคุณนี้ให้เปลี่ยนเร็ว
เปลี่ยนเร็วใช่
เพราะว่าตอนที่ขับรถไปใช่ไหมครับย้ายอย่า
จะขับรถเนี่ยจับเมืองที่คุณนิดนั่ง
เครื่องบินไปเนี้ยขับไปที่ที่คุณนิดจะ
เดินเขานะมันสูงกว่า
อย่างเมืองที่คุณนิดนั่งเครื่องบินไป
เนี่ยความสูงจะอยู่ที่ 5,000 ชุดใช่ไหม
ครับ
คุณนิดเนี่ย
ใช่ก็
5,000 บาทแล้วที่เนื้อคุณนี้จะก็ขับรถไป
อีกเมืองนึงเพื่อไปเดินเขาเมืองนั้นน่ะ
สูงประมาณ
หนึ่งหมื่น 0 ใช่
12,000
[เพลง]
อากาศมันก็ยิ่งหนาวคือ
แค่ 5,000 ก็ยังหนาวและนี้สูงขึ้นไปอีก
ก็ตอนที่ถูกนี้ไปเนี่ยตรงเมืองแรกเนี่ย
อากาศประมาณ
15 องศาเซลเซียส
อ่ะค่ะใหญ่แล้วพอไปอีกเมืองหนึ่งที่เดิน
ขาวเนี่ย 0 เข้าแล้วบนเสาเนี่ยอ่ะคะคู่
นี้
มันก็หนาวขึ้นประมาณ
ติดลบติดลบสองติดลบสามนั้นครับค่ะลบสอง
แล้วครูนิคเดินขึ้นแล้วนอนบนเขาไหมคะหรือ
ว่าเดินเครื่องแล้วก็เดินเดินขึ้นแล้วก็
เดินลงครับใช่ท้ายเพราะว่าแสนคูณนิเขาทุก
ไม่ชอบนอนแบบกลางเต็นท์นอนก็บอกมันลำบาก
มันมันไม่สบาย
แล้วคืนนี้ก็ชอบไหมผู้ที่ชอบนอนกันเต็ม
ไว้ฮะคุณนิคชอบนะใช่คือคุณที่กาดจะชอบ
เดินเขาเดินป่าแล้วก็นอนกลางเต๊นครูนิค
คิดว่ามันโอ๊ยลูกทีค่ะได้ตากแฟนคุณนิพนธ์
ชอบสบาย
ว่าจริงๆที่ประเทศไทยก็ไม่ค่อยได้มีโอกาส
ได้ทำนะคือแบบเดินคือ
จริงๆที่ไทยคุณนี้เคยแค่หนึ่งครั้งคือไป
ที่อ่างขางอ่ะที่หาดอ๋ออ๋อทางทั้งๆตื่น
ขึ้นมาได้ไพ่
ใช่ตกแค่นั้นครั้งเดียวเลยที่จากเห็นนอน
กับเพื่อน
ก็สนุกดียังจำได้เลยว่าตอนนั้นเนี่ยไป
อังคารใช่ไหมครับกางเต็นท์นอนแล้วมันเป็น
ช่วงฤดูหนาวแล้วกูนี่ก็โอ้ยหนาวเหมือนที่
นี่เลยคือน่าจะ 0 องศาค่ะคุณดี
god-king แค่ข้าวแล้วไม่โต๊ะอ่ะใต้โต๊ะ
กินข้าวครับหมอเขามีเหมือนกับเป็นเตาหมู
กระทะเอาไว้อุ่นนะไม่ได้เอาไว้กิน
อย่างนี้หรออันนี้นะถ้านักเรียนใช่มา
ประเทศไทยอาจจะเคยเห็นผงเตาหมูกระทะนะ
เนี่ยเอ่อเอาใช่
น่ะเขาก็ตั้งไว้ใต้โต๊ะหรือคุณจะว่าโต๊ะ
สมมติเนี่ยเป็นโอ๊ะจะมา The คนนี้จะลบภู
เขาออกก่อน
คุณแฟน
ค่ะ
ก็นั่ง
ขอมันหนาวทราย
ไม่เนาะน้องจุดไฟอ่ะเนอะเวลามันหนาวใช่ๆ
แต่ที่ที่กูนี้ไปเที่ยวเนี่ยมันไม่มีไฟ
ให้อุ่นคุณนี้ก็ต้องหาเสื้อใส่ประมาณสาม
ชั้นใส่ 3 ตัว
ชายอากาศใจเย็นน้องนอนหนาวเย็นใช่ๆครับ
แต่ก็สนุกครับสนุกก็วิวสวยขับถ่ายก็กาด
บุกนะชายๆ
คนเล็กตัวคุณนิคจะให้ดูรูปอันนี้คือที่
ครูนิไปเที่ยวมาเหรอคะใช่ๆครับได้ค่ะคือ
ไป 4 วันก็เดินวันละ 1 ที่หรือเปล่าคะถ้า
ใช่ๆครับ
เดินวันละหนึ่งที่เพราะว่าเดินขึ้นเดินลง
ก็ใช้เวลาประมาณ
5-6 ชั่วโมงแล้วๆใช้อันนี้น่าจะกดใช้
ด่วนก็เหนื่อยแล้วเนาะตัว E นะเพราะว่า
คู่นี้ชอบเดินป่าเดินเขาอะไรบ่อเมริกาน่า
จะมีหลายๆที่ให้เราไปเที่ยวเดินเขาได้มี
สียังไม่ชอบไม่เหมือนคุณเองอ่ะผู้หญิงไม่
ชอบ
ไม่ชอบก็ไม่เคยด้วยล่ะค่ะเรารู้สึกเราไม่
ชอบเราก็เลยไม่เคยไปเดินป่าไม่เคยกาง
เต็นท์ไงอ๋อคุณนิคเนี่ยชอบวิ่งก็เลย 5
ได้เดินเยอะๆเนี่ยคุณนิคโอเคอ่าผู้หญิง
ชอบนั่ง
อันนี้ครับอันเนี่ยเต้นเป็นภูเขาอันนี้
คือบนภูเขานะอันนี้เป็นภูเขาที่ไม่มีหิมะ
ค่ะอันนี้ครับเดินขึ้นไปก็ตอนกลางวันอัน
นี้ก็สวยขาวสวยใช่อันนี้ก็ที่ไปอันนี้
เป็นอันที่สามขาที่ศาลไปเราก็คุณนี้จะให้
ดูอันนี้อันนี้เป็นทะเลสาบอันเนี่ยที่คุย
คุณนิดบอกว่ามันมีหิมะค่ะไม่ใช่ผู้หญิงก็
เห็นหิมะอยู่ค่ะโอ้นี่ไงอันนี้ขายอีกมะ
ใช่พี่มาสเต็มไปหมดเลยมีไหนอยู่บนต้นไม้
บนพื้นดักนี้ครับๆอันนี้ก็ก็อันนี้เป็น
อันที่สองอันนี้ฮากนี่่เดี๋ยวคนนึกจะให้
ดูอันแรกเนี่ยมันจะ
ก็มีหิมะแล้วนะจริงๆอันแรกเนี่ยจะเป็นแค่
แค่นั่นจะเป็นภูเขาแต่เป็นภูเขาที่
มันเป็นแบบนี้ครับอ๋อเหมือนภูเขาหินไหมคะ
ได้เป็นหินชายครับอันนี้จะเดินไม่เยอะ
ประมาณ 1 ชั่วโมงค่ะเสร็จเนี่ยผู้หญิง
เห็นอันนี้ใช่ไหมครับจริงๆแล้วตรงนี้
เนี่ยตรงกลางอ่ะมันเป็นที่ที่เขาจัดเวลา
มีคอนเสิร์ตหลวงพ่อใช่ก็คือตรงนี้เนี่ย
มันเป็นบนภูเขาให้คนเนี่ยเดินเขาแล้วก็
เวลาเขามีงานใหญ่ๆ
ว่าจะไปที่นั่นเพราะมีคอนเสิร์ตข้างนอก
ๆแต่เขาก็เขาก็พูดขำๆกันตลกๆนะว่าก็ถ้า
อยากมางานที่นี่ห้องออกกำลังกาย
ไม่งั้นเดียวเดินเสร็จแล้วไม่มีแรงเต้น
ไม่มีแรงดูคอนเสิร์ตเดินเสร็จแล้วก็หลับ
ดีกว่าโอ้มันเหนื่อยมากมันเหนื่อยครับ
เพราะว่าเนี่ยคือผู้หญิงเห็นเหมือนมันจะ
ไม่สูงนะแต่เราต้องเดินจากตรงพื้นข้างๆ
เนี่ยข้างล่างเนี่ยขึ้นไปตรงเนี้ยมันก็
ไม่ง่ายนะ
ก็ไม่ได้เป็นทางทางเรียบๆมันก็ต้องมันฟิต
ร้านจ่ายให้หลับชินกับการเดินอ่ะใช่ใช่
เนี่ยเขาก็
ที่คุณนิดไปเที่ยวมาก็เป็นคลิปของครูนิด
นะคุณนิดนะครูนี้มี
สีเทาคำว่าทริปแล้วก็ครูนิคเอามารวมกัน
เราไปเที่ยวมาคุณก็มาเล่าให้นักเรียนฟัง
แต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้มันหมดเวลาแล้วเนาะเดี๋ยว
เราก็มาเจอกับนักเรียนใหม่ในวีดีโอหน้านะ
คะครับได้ไว้เจอกันครับโอเคก็
ครับอ่า